did you know that in 2018 the author of
Attack on Titan revealed what it would
look like if an Ackerman had royal blood
during that interview he said that if a
child was born between the Ackerman
family and the royal family then both
Bloodlines would be equally represented
this means that the child would have all
the perks of being a royal combined with
having the awakened super strength of an
Ackerman and Immunity from the founding
Titan it's important to remember that
we've seen the even Royal blooded
characters can have their memories
altered by the founder but an Ackerman
with Royal Blood would have been
completely immune